les ovnis ces fameux objets volants non
identifiés sont revenus en force
la séparation entre la science et
l'irrationnel devient moins précise et
parfois même l'imagination l'emportent
sur la certitude depuis des millénaires
c et reviennent sur la terre on pense
que nous sommes nous les terriens le
résultat d'une de leurs expériences
alors deux autres ils viennent voir où
nous en sommes et il existe des milliers
de témoignages de l'atterrissage de ces
engins ils sont deux à s'être approché
de cette barrière
patrick 21 ans profondément choqué ne
veut plus voir personne
c'est dans l'anonymat qu'il a accepté de
raconter ce qu'il a vu arriver à
quelques centaines de mètres de
l'endroit où vous voyons l'objet le
moteur s'est arrêté des phares ma radio
qui étaient allumés s'est éteinte sans
raison bande sans raison apparente
l'objet qui a atterri lundi une
modification du champ magnétique locales
et santé - canular ne peut pas inventer
un truc pareil nous avions l'impression
que c'était un anneau un anneau qui qui
tourner lentement et de sa s'est détaché
un cône une forme de quartier de tarte
et ensuite l'objet a disparu
complètement l'objet avant de
disparaître à arrêter dossier sur lui
même mais très rapidement
ce n'était plus qu'un point en ciel ils
ont la possibilité de passer d'un
univers alex à ce moment exactement en
tant qu il alors ça il faut le prouver
bien sûr mais je pense que ça appartient
ou à la génération qui viennent je
dépose générations futures car nous
approchons peu à peu de la vérité